[Musique]
il aurait pu faire partie du ps biya il
aurait pu faire partie de la série à
il aurait pu faire partie du gign
mais ils ont raté le concours ils sont
agents de surveillance de la voie
publique d'alain peuvent tuer ils font
régner l'ordre et un savoir s il sur la
ville
leur manière
[Musique]
prennent des risques démesurés ils sont
les meilleurs
au parti de l'ailé
réputé pour ne jamais rien laisser
passer
ils n'en sont pas moins dépourvu d'un
grand coeur
votre voiture ça monsieur way est au
courant qu'on ait le 16 du mois alors le
stationnement est autorisé du côté pair
entre le 16 et le 31 du mois vous êtes
garé au numéro 13 de la rue monsieur on
va devoir vous verbaliser sa frappe 22e
l'euro quoi on a ça fait même pas deux
minutes que je suis garé là enfin le
problème ça monsieur
attendez qu est ce que je vois là vous
êtes sur une place handicapée un non non
non mais bah si pourtant je vois pas le
petit macaron qu'est ce qui se passe je
n'ai pas vu de marquage au sol c'est ça
non mais j'ai pas fait gaffe j'étais un
peu près si j'avais un truc à faire
l'algérie à 135 euros 170 euros
exactement parce que je ne vois que
monsieur aussi sur une face livraison
quoi ou très juste non mais faut pas
abuser joue pas sur une place libre et
sont juste une roue qui déborde ça
compte pas ça ça compte quand même joué
à quoi l'a voulu que la butte ça par
contre ça c'est pas possible
parce que je tire une balle dans la tête
ça voulait s'afficher à pas du tout
pourquoi vous balayer comme ça parce
qu'on fait que le petit et monsieur
directement sur notre métier
comment vous appeler monsieur bien vous
savez quoi tony
on dirait que leur métier calmez vous
ben on voulait continuer à mettre des
amendes
j'ai pas que ça à faire l'interview
[Applaudissements]
et à
[Musique]
la fille et deux yeux comme ça
félicitations monsieur c'est du bon
boulot
on a fait notre métier monsieur le
préfet
c'est avec beaucoup d'honneur que je
vous fais détective façon à ce que vous
puissiez protéger la ville comme elle le
mérite
nous sommes très honorés monsieur le
préfet ça sera non
quelle zone
quel homme
quelle fin
ça c'est des bonhommes quand un homme et
son uniforme ne font qu'un rien ni
personne ne peut les séparer
continuerons à protéger la ville à leur
manière un stationnement gênant
[Musique]
à beaune toi à multiprise subscribe dans
les moments somme tout cas à benoît à
multi un belge la multiprise abonne toi
à multiplexage abonne toi à multiprise
c'est en nouvelle calédonie c'est en
manque d'inspiration
[Rires]